hello everyone and welcome to another
video on python programming
this video is going to be the first of a
part of a series on object oriented
programming
so to start off with let's try to
understand and get an introduction into
what is
object oriented programming well as the
name suggests object oriented
programming is
all about creating objects an object is
a group of interrelated variables and
functions
variables can be referred to as the
properties of the object
whereas the functions can be referred to
as the behavior of an object so if we
were to treat say for example a car
as an object its properties would be its
color its model
its price and its brand whereas its
behavior
or functions for that matter would be
like accelerating
gear change breaking similarly if i give
you an example of a dog as an object
we could consider the properties of the
dog as its weight
or its name its breed its color whereas
its functions could be
say barking playing eating walking etc
objects provide a better and a clear
structure for
a program now lets move on to what is a
class and an instance
now a class is like a blueprint or a
template of
certain functions and entities whereas
an instance
is a particular realization of a class
classes are used to create user-defined
data structures
and define certain functions called
methods within the class
whereas instances are realizations of
these classes
and when we are speaking of classes and
instances
classes don't contain any real data they
are just merely templates
instances on the other hand contain real
data to
think of an example of the difference
between a class and an instance
think of a class like a empty form
or a questionnaire now an empty form of
a questionnaire does not have any
information
but it does have a template to it it
tells you to fill in certain information
and based on who is filling in the
information that information or the data
on a particular form will be different
so an instance is like a filled out form
with its own unique set of information
that is one way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and an instance
now for our first example on classes i
will be taking you through
a class where i've defined based on
the circle object so this class is going
to define basically information about
your general circle such as its radius
and its area
so let's go through it now obviously to
define a class we need a keyword
well in the case of classes we use the
class keyword followed by
a name for that class so in this case my
name
is circle now after the colon
every every information that is part of
the class has to be obviously indented
as is typical for python
now you can see over here a bunch of def
keywords
followed by so something that you might
not be familiar with
and i will try to get you through this
so if you see here
you have a def keyword followed by init
and this init
is prefixed by a double underscore and
it's suffixed by a double underscore and
you can see the same thing for str and
repr
well this double underscore is called a
dunder and any method
these are of course methods this is a
method this is a method this is a method
this is a method
now any method that is prefixed and
suffixed by double underscores
are called dunder methods um these
dunder methods
are or can be thought of like predefined
or built in
methods for any class that you define so
these we have
like a three under methods over here and
we have one user defined method
that we will get to so this first method
that you see here is the init method
or the initialization method and this is
invoked or called
whenever we create an instance of this
class circle
and what we do here is basically we pass
when we create this instant circle uh we
are what
what happens is that we are we get an
option to pass
an a value for a
what is this keyword or variable radius
so if i pass so you will see me uh later
on creating an instance
where um i will be passing a value and
that value is basically stored as the
radius
and by default the radius that will be
passed whenever
we create an instance for this class is
one
um the str method is basically used to
return a descriptive string
for the the instance of um class
um our api is not something that you
have to bother with right now
and uh now get area is something that
you should follow because
if you see here i have not used any
double underscores so this is a user
user defined method um user defined
methods are
it's a method that we define and these
are like tasks that we
define on our own so in my user defined
method called get area
i will be returning the area of the
circle based on the radius that i passed
to it
now if you notice here the before every
um
in every method i have the self keyword
before any other attribute so like this
herself this herself even the get area
herself
now what this means um self is like an
optional keyword
that is used to improve readability of a
program first of all
and it's also the function of the self
keyword is basically
telling python that well any of the
methods that we are invoking
in this class or the instance of this
class has to refer to
attributes and variables within that
instance of that class
so if i'm going to use get area function
i am going to
get values and attribute values and
variable values based on
only the current instance of that
particular class
self is obviously optional we don't
really need it
but basically the first attribute of any
method
is is basically the is basically
what the met is is the instance that um
the method
is invoked upon so if i say self i'm
telling
this particular function that okay all
the value that you're going to get for
performing whatever task you want is
going to be found in that
particular instance where you have been
invoked itself now don't worry if all
this is very confusing
this might be in the beginning but just
try to understand that
this is something that we do for good
practice and you will understand
when 20 yourself or when not to yourself
as you learn about object
oriented programming so if you see here
my get area function
is supposed to return the value radius
times radius self.radius is basically
telling um
whatever value i've passed for radius
for that particular
instance you can read this as radius
times radius times pi
as well so obviously this is pi r
squared which is the area of a
particular circle
now let me show you an example where i
am going to perform some of these
functions
so if you see this first line i have
created an instance of the class circle
where i've passed 2.1 for the radius of
the circle
so now the value of the variable radius
in this particular instance is going to
be stored as 2.1
and this particular instance is going to
be stored in the variable c1
now the print c1 function invokes the
str
self-defined or predefined function now
if you remember str was
it's basically used to return a
particular
string that describes like what the
class will do and this is something that
we define on our own
in our example str will return the uh
the string saying this is a circle with
radius off and then it will return the
radius that we passed so in this case it
should say this is the circle of radius
2.1 as you can see over here so if i
execute this you can notice this line
this is a circle with radius 2.1 and
this is invoked by
the print function the print basically
invokes the dunder str function
which does all of this now in the next
line we say print
c1 dot get area so this is going to
print the value of
the what what gets returned when we
invoke the method get area for this
particular instance c1
so obviously in this particular instance
our radius is 2.1 so the get area
function should do pi times 2.1 square
and the value is as you can see here is
some 13.85
so that is the area that we got now if
we want to print a particular radius
um we just say print c1 dot radius so
this will print the value of what is
what is stored in radius for the
particular instance c1 now you might
notice me using a dot
whenever it comes to defining a certain
function or a keyword well
anytime that we want to invoke or use a
method of a particular class
we have to use the dot keyword so we use
the instance name
c1 dot followed by whatever method that
we want to use so if we want to use the
get area function we say c1 dot get area
if you want to find out what is there in
the radius
key radius variable of a particular
instance we say c1 dot radius
now before we move on let's talk about
some of the naming conventions
class names are initial capitalized so
if our
class name is um for example um
like for example if it's camel case well
each word
that is part of this class has its first
letter capitalized
variables and method names are in lower
class so if my class
was called circle we say class circle
with c
being in capital now moving on let's
talk about how we initialize or define
instance variables now instance
variables are declared within the init
method
if you remember from the earlier example
of circle init is a dunder method
it's followed and it's preceded by
double underscore as you can see here
now if you see in this particular case i
have again used the self keyword and as
i mentioned earlier
the self keyword is the first parameter
of all member methods
um and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation
so every time a new circle object is
created the dot
init function sets the initial state of
the object by assigning the values of
the object's properties
so the init function basically
initializes each
and every new instance of whatever of
our class
so we can give in at any number of
parameters but the first parameter must
always be a variable
called self now when a new class
instance is created
the instance is automatically passed to
the self parameter in init so that new
attributes can be defined on the object
inside the init method the self.radius
basically means
that we want the value of radius
based on the current instance itself so
as you can see
radius defines an instance variable
radius and we're going to use
the particular instance and its value of
for radius
in our variable radius now instance uh
the
i mean the init function is not a
constructor but it is an
initializer to create instance variables
the init function also will never return
a value
and it is optional and can be omitted if
there are no instance variables
now let's move on to um class variables
so now as we mentioned earlier all the
attributes that are created inside the
init function
are instant specific attributes and the
instance
attributes are obviously specific to a
particular instance of the class
for example all dog objects now if we
have a class called dog then all dog
objects have a name and age
but the values for the name and age will
vary depending on which dog we are
talking
talking about or basically which
instance of the dog are we talking about
now class attributes are attributes that
have the same value for all class
instances and we define a class
attribute by
assigning a value value to a variable
outside of the init function so if you
look at this example over here
we have created another class called
circle and we have this initializer
again
where we have a class specific variable
called radius
which whose value will change depending
on whatever we pass for that particular
instance
however if you look before the initial
the init
init function or the initializer
function if you see here we have another
variable called shape object
which stores the string circle and this
variable is going to be the same and
constant for every instance
of the class circle and unlike the
variable radius we will not have
different values depending on a
particular instance
okay now let's talk about instantiating
an object and let's see what happens
when we create two different instances
of the same class
so as you can see here i've created an
instance c1 for class circle
and i'm going to check its id well if
you see the id is
something like this now if i created
another instance
over here called c2 and if i check its
id well it's something different now so
if you see each instance
basically has a different memory
location in our memory
and each instance is this is how each
instance is different
each time we create it and they are
created in different memory locations
finally before we conclude this topic on
the introduction into oop let's talk
about class methods
instance methods and static methods now
class methods
are usually declared are actually
declared with the
at class method operator or decorator as
you can see here
it accepts the class as its first
argument so in this case i am going to
say i'm going to define a class called
my class
i'm going to use this at class method
decorator to say that whatever follows
here
is going to be a class method and i've
defined a class method called hello that
takes in
a um that uses again self and a name
attribute so what this does is it prints
um whatever i have uh passed to it in
the form of hello from
uh self.name now what this this is going
to do is basically
it's going to give out a string saying
hello from name of
the whatever class we have and whatever
we pass
the attribute name so oh in this my
particular
in this case i'm going to invoke this
method using the class name itself i'm
not going to use an instance name
because i have no instance
in this particular example and since
this is a class method it can be invoked
using the class name itself so i'm going
to pass rakesh and let's see what
happens
when we do this as you can see the first
print will basically
give us the information of the class
itself it's saying that the class
is called my class and the second print
statement
is basically a string saying hello from
the string name my class
with a comma and then whatever we passed
initially which was rakish
next is then instance methods and these
are the most common types of methods
these are invoked by an instance object
so we have to create an instance to
actually use an instance method
and it takes the instance or the keyword
itself as its first argument
so if i say class dot class uh if i
define a class my class in this example
and i'm going to define another function
called hello as you can see i have not
used any
decorator like at class method so this
is going to be an instance method
and it's going to be invoked by the
particular instance so in this case it's
going to print
hello from and it's going to basically
say the name of the class again
so i create my instance called my
instance1 and it's an instance of this
class
and then i'm going to invoke the
instance method by using the
dot operator and the instance name and
the result will be basically
this string over here as you can see now
finally we have another type of method
called the static method
which is declared using the add static
method decorator so a static method
does not know its class and is just
attached to the class for convenience
it does not depend on the state of the
object and could be from a separate
function of a module
a static method can be invoked via a
class object or
an instance object so if you look at
this example over here i have defined a
static method i've defined hello and it
basically says print
hello world so it's going to basically
just print this so
if you can see here i've created my
instance and i'm going to say dot hello
it should basically pre-print print
hello world that's all
in our next video we will be covering
the next topics of op and we will be
starting with inheritance
in our next video inheritance is used to
describe the relationship between two
classes
wherein one class takes the methods and
properties from another class
in this relationship we have something
called the base class
or the parent class from which we will
derive all
our sum of the properties and methods
and the
class which actually derives these
properties and methods
is known as the derived class so you can
think of the derived class as a
specialized version of a base class
to explain what inheritance is in a
basic way i will show you
an example where i'm creating a cylinder
class which is going to be a subclass of
the circle class that you might have
encountered in
the earlier video on op so what we're
going to do is create a cylinder class
that is a subclass of circle where we're
going to get the attributes radius and
get area from circle class
and we're going to add the attributes
height and get volume to the cylinder
so right off the start you can see we
have our class
circle that you might have seen in the
earlier video so this class circle has
the familiar initialization where we are
supposed to enter a value for a radius
that gets stored in self dot radius
now we also have a description string
which basically is
a dunder method that returns a string
when we
invoke the print command on a particular
instance
and we have the get area method as well
now if we move on to the cylinder class
you can see that i'm defining this class
with the class keyword with the cylinder
name
but you can see that i have added a
parenthesis and within it i have
mentioned the name
of the super class that i want the
cylinder class to be a subclass
of so this is how we actually define a
subclass
in the most basic way you enter the name
that you want
and you enter the name of the superclass
that you want the subclass to be
if a subclass of in parenthesis right
after the name
now next if you move on to the dunder
initialization
um the initialization is very familiar
familiar except
now we have another attribute for height
which has a deep default value of 1
just like the radius so this basically
means that we have an option of entering
two different attributes for our
cylinder instances
now if you see here there's a line which
says super dot init now this is like
this is a command which we use to invoke
the
super classes initializer so anytime we
create an instance for cylinder
we also want an initialization for the
circle method
as well as a part of our cylinder
instance next you can see
that much like how we stored self uh i
mean the radius attribute
in self.radius we're also storing the
height attribute in self.height
now even this cylinder class has an str
method to return a particular string if
we use this
print function and finally we get on to
a more
a new method that we have defined only
for this render class called get volume
now uh if you see the get volume it
returns as basically the volume of the
cylinder that is being described in the
particular instance
for which we enter the height and the
radius so if you can see here
what we basically added extra is an a
height attribute
and another method called get volume and
the other parts of
the circle superclass such as radius and
get area
are also going to be a part of cylinder
even though you do not explicitly see
them anywhere here
and we will see how in uh in the form of
an example that's coming up
so let me just execute these classes now
that that's done
i'm going to create an instance for
cylinder i'm going to store it in
cy1 and i'm going to pass 1.1 for the
radius and 2.2 for the height
and once that is done let's just print
to invoke the hdr method
and as you can see the sdi method
basically tells us the information that
is a cylinder with radius 1.1 and height
2.2
so now let's print what is the value we
get when
we use the get area method now it's
important to note get area was not
explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass
but it's a method that is a part of the
circle superclass and we can see that we
can actually access methods that are
part of the superclass
simply by accessing any other method so
if you use the dot get area
you can see that we get a value for the
area of
the cylinder so this basic this area is
basically the area of the circle
face of the cylinder the top or the
bottom now let's use
now let's invoke the subclass specific
method
which is the get volume method in a
similar manner as you can see
just by doing invoking this method we
get the volume as well
now if we want to see what is the radius
and the height we can just do a simple
print statement followed by cy1 dot
radius c1 dot height and it gives us
both of these values as you can see here
now over here what i'm going to do is
create another instance of cylinder but
i'm not going to pass anything for
radius
or height so basically it's going to
take the default values for radius and
height which was
one and one respectively so once i print
um
this is this statement is basically
going to print the str method or
whatever we stored in the sdr which is
basically the description of the object
followed by what is its radius and
height this method will give us the area
and this method will give us the volume
so once i execute this as you can see
here this is what we get
and this is what we expect as well so
now in this example what i'm going to
show you
is uh now i'm going to go back and i am
going to
create another instance for circle now
this is the superclass of course
and i'm going to give it and since the
superclass has only one option
uh one attribute that we can enter which
is for the radius
so i pass 3.3 and i'm gonna print what
what happens when i just print
uh this instance it's going to basically
give us whatever was
a part of the htr method uh after that
i'm going to print
is instance this is this is basically a
check on whether
c1 is an instance of this class circle
and x i'm going to check if c1 is an
instance of
its subclass cylinder now when i execute
this you can see
that well this is what we this is the
str method that gets printed but if you
see here
you can see that it says c1 is indeed a
an instance of circle when it says true
over here
but when we look at the next line is c1
and instance of cylinder it says false
and this is obviously because
a superclass object is never an instance
of a subclass object well as
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
python
so there are basically five types of
inheritance in python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical
and hybrid inheritance so we will go one
by one and see each of these examples
starting off we have the single
inheritance this is simply where we have
one base class and one derived class
from that base class so this is a simple
single inheritance and in this example
you can see i have a class called
country
where i have a method that i've defined
called show country which is basically
going to say
print this is india it's basically going
to print this every time we invoke this
show country method
then we have a class called state which
derives
from the superclass called country where
we have a method called
show state which is going to say print
this state every time
so you can see i created an instance of
the class state and
i'm through that instance i can access
the super class and the
subclass methods over here next we have
the multi-level uh sorry multiple
inheritance
and this is when a derived class
contains more than one base class
so let's look at an example to
understand this so if you can see here i
have a class called student
with the two methods defined called
method one and method two
in method one we can pass uh two
attributes sn
sno or i think is this this is supposed
to be like uh
an id i guess like sn number and we have
s name so this is basically two
attributes we can pass
um that are probably descriptors for a
student and um
in the next method you have basically
two print statements which says
student number and then they will print
the student number
and uh it will also print the student
name um next we have a class called
marks
this is also um so these these two
classes are basically what our super
classes are going to be and we're going
to derive
a third class from these two so this
second class is
a class called marks and we have two
methods again
one method is called set marks which has
um the option of putting in two
attributes m1 and m2
both are representative of the two marks
and we store them in self dot mach 1
self talk mark 2.
the second method is put marks which is
going to print the marks
namely mark 1 and then it's going to
tell us how much marks are there in the
first
subject for example and another print
statement doing the same thing for
the second subject of mark two finally
we have a third class
called a result which derives from two
classes marks and student as you can see
here
in my parenthesis i've passed in marks
and student both are super classes
and our class result is going to derive
from both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result i have
two methods specific to this derived
class called calc
wherein i'm going to basically calculate
the two the total marks
of um uh the the total marks which is
basically the addition of mark one plus
mark two
and i'm then i'm going to have another
method called put total which is going
to print me
what is the total so if you can see here
i have created an instance of this
derived class called
a result and i'm storing it in r then
i'm going to access
method one which is obviously a method
from the first superclass called student
and i'm going to store okay so this is a
name is i guess lucky and he has 60
marks
secondly then i'm going to do our set
marks which is the method from the
second super class
which is going to set the marks uh
respectively so you have lucky student
and his id is
60 and he has got 50 and 60 marks
respectively
in say the first two subjects and
finally i'm going to access
the derived class method called calc so
this is going to do the sum
uh finally i'm going to also do our
method 2 which is
i'm going to print our student number
and
student name next we're going to have
put marks which is going to tell us
the um what are the individual marks for
mark 1 and mark 2 and then finally we're
going to print the total marks
with the put total so once i execute
this you can see here it says student
number
60 student name lucky marks one is 50 as
i had written here
marks to 60 as i passed here and then
total is 110 which is basically 50 plus
60.
my next type of inheritance is called
multi-level inheritance now multi-level
inheritance can be assumed as
where you take a super class let's call
it a and you derive a class
b from that class a now what if we
derived a class
c from b and we kept doing this so until
say a class e now each of these steps is
uh
in its own an inheritance but this whole
relationship can be described
as a multi-level inheritance so um let's
take an example again so i've
this this time i've defined a class
called student
where i have defined two methods called
set stud and
put stud or you can call it set student
and put student
in my first method i have options of
adding two attributes
again this is the student number this is
the student name in my second
method i am going to print what is the
student number and what is the student
name
finally uh so sorry next we have another
class called marks
which derives from the first class
called student
this has two methods called set marks
where i'm going to again get the option
of
adding two integers for m1 and m2
which is going to represent mark 1 and
mark 2 and finally i have put marks
the method which is going to print mark
1 and mark 2.
finally i have another class called
result and this
if you see um this derives from marks
now if you see this relationship you'll
notice result derives from marks
whereas marks itself derives from
student and this is an example of
multi-level
hierarchy and even as a part of this
third class we have its own
methods called calc and put total um
calc will calculate the total as we had
seen earlier and
put total will basically print that
total and we're going to do a very
similar operation we're going to create
an instance of this third class uh
result and store it in r
um then we're going to do basically
we're going to set the student details
uh his uh student number and his name
we're going to give him his marks 50 and
60. we're going to calculate
what are the total we're going to say
okay now put the details
of what is the student's number and name
we're going to also store
enter i mean display his marks mark 1
and mark 2 and finally we're going to
display the total marks so let's execute
this
and if you see it's basically the
similar operation that we did earlier
but the only difference is in the
earlier example our
our third class result was derived from
marks and student together
so this was an example of multiple
inheritance whereas in this example
the result class derives from marks and
marks
itself derives from students so this is
an example of multi-level inheritance
finally we have um sorry not finally
penultimately we have
as our fourth example of inheritance
called a hierarchical inheritance
apart in my mispronounciation it's
hierarchical inheritance
so in this case a base class basically
will contain more than one derived class
so let's see a look at an example of
what we mean here so
i have a class called one where i have
defined a method called display
where what i'm going to do is i'm going
to store self.x is equal to
1000 and self.y is equal to 2000. then
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
print a statement saying this is the
method in class one and i'm going to say
after that i'm going to print another
statement saying value of x is a self.x
which is going to be 1000.
uh then i'm going to have another print
statement saying value of y is
self dot y which is going to be 2 000.
finally
i mean next i have another class called
two this
this is going to derive from class one
as you can see here and in this class
two i have defined another method called
add
and in this method add what i'm going to
do is i'm going to first print a
statement saying this is the method in
class 2
and then i'm going to actually print the
result of
x plus y which is 1 000 plus 2 000.
finally i have another class
called 3 and this is also deriving from
1. so if you notice
we have one parent class called one and
from this one
parent class we're going to derive two
different subclasses called two and
three so this is an example of
hierarchical
inheritance now in this class three what
i've done is i've defined a
multiplication
method what i'm going to do is print
first of all i'm going to print this
when i invoke this method that this is
the method in class 3 finally i'm going
to say
uh i'm going to print the result of x
times y which is 1000 times
2000 so if you see i am going to create
an instance of 2 and i'm going to create
an
instance of three and i'm going to store
them in t1 and d2 now since
uh t2 i mean t1 is an instance of two
so i can access its methods add and i
can access this methods display so i'm
going to use t1.display
and even it into t2 i mean since it's a
class
it's an instance of class 3 and this
also derives from class 1
i can also access its method display but
now i cannot access add but i can access
multiply so if you see here i
access add through t1 instance since add
is a part of
class 2 whereas multiply
is a method in class 3 so i access it in
its respective
instance which is t2 so if you see here
now once i execute this
what you will get is basically the
results
so first of all it will basically
display the method from
class 1 which is the display method it
will display the values of x and y
and since i've done this twice from two
different instances
it will basically show a repetition over
here finally i've done the addition and
since this is
a method in class 2 it is going to say
as much that this is a method in class 2
and then it's going to say x
5 is 3 000. and now multiply is a method
in the third class so it's going to say
this is a
method in class 3 and it's going to tell
me what is the multiplication result
finally we have what is called hybrid
inheritance and this is a combination of
multiple plus
multi-level inheritance that you saw
earlier so
let's again understand this through this
example so we have a class called
student
where we have a method called set
student um again
two attributes we can pass here for
student number and student name
next we have a another method part of
the class student called put student so
this will print us the student number
and student name
next we have a class called marks and
this
marks inherits from student so uh we
have a method in
class marks called cell set marks where
we can pass
two attributes for mark 1 and mark 2
respectively
and as we had seen earlier we also have
a put marks which will display
the marks for marks 1 and marks 2. we
have a class called practical
the spectacle is basically a another
super class
if you see here since this does not
derive from anything it is super class
on its own and what it does
is it uh it has two methods get
practical
um and we can uh pass an attribute for
p1 here and we store that in self.p1 and
then we have an attribute
for put practical which will print us
the practical mark whatever we passed
for this attribute in p1
finally if you see we have a class
called result now in this result
we have we are going to derive from
marks
and practical but if you notice here
marks itself
is a subclass of student so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
whereas since result derives from marx
and practical both it is also an example
of multiple inheritance so if you see
notice here
this is an example of multiple and
multiple level inheritance
which is basically what we call hybrid
inheritance and as
we had seen earlier this result class
will have a calc method
to do a total of the marks
in this case mark 1 plus mark 2 plus the
practical mark b1
and we have a put total method which is
basically going to print us the total so
now we're going to create an instance of
this result
and through this instance of result
we're going to first invoke
the parent class method called set
student which is the
the second level parent basically the
student the student
class um said student method so we're
going to set student here we're going to
say 60 is a student id
and name is ash then we have set marks
which is again
the the second level parent which is a
student class
um where we set the marks finally we
access this get practical now if you
notice get practical is part of
the practical uh super class so in this
we store the third subject or the the
practical marks hundred
then we calculate the total and we put
uh first the student details then we put
the individual marks then we put the
practical marks and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number is 60 student name and
all the basically whatever details we
wanted
um is shown over here so this was it
guys for
um our video on inheritance again we
will continue with our topic of
object oriented programming with the
topic of polymorphism in the next video
now the term polymorphism in oop refers
to the ability of an object to adapt the
code to the type of data it is
processing polymorphism is one of the
key concepts of python
and it is also a built-in feature of
python an example to get us started
on polymorphism would be how we use the
plus operator
we use the plus operator not only for
arithmetic additions but we also use the
plus operator
for stuff like string concatenations or
joining two lists together
this example where we are able to use
the plus operator for different
different operations is an example of
polymorphism
to show you what i mean i have basically
done a simple addition operation here
where i'm adding two variables number
one and number two
when i do it on integers it basically
adds one plus two
now when i use it on two strings str1
and str2
which contains python and programming
two separate uh
strings and when i use the plus operator
on these you can see what
it does here it forms um one string
containing both of these individual
strings
so this is basically the plus operator
showing polymorphism and is one of the
simplest
occurrences and yet most common
occurrences
of polymorphism in python another
example of polymorphism would be
through the lens function the lens
function in python is
something that we use a lot and over
multiple data types
depending on the data type that we use
the length function for
we get a different value or a different
sort of information from the length
function
now if you see here from this diagram
when we use the length function on a
string it gives us the length of the
string when we use the
length function on a list it gives us
the number of items whereas if we use
the length function on a dictionary it
gives us
the number of keys so this is well
another example of how we have
polymorphism in a function
now what we're going to do is look at
the different techniques through which
we can enable polymorphisms in our code
our first example that we are going to
look at
is through method overloading now method
overloading in its traditional sense
where we can have a method with the same
name uh more than one method with the
same name
in the same class is not exactly
possible in python so if we have
multiple methods with the same name in a
class in python
which may differ in in types and number
of arguments
are not allowed and not supported in
python in fact if we did something like
this
where we created a method with uh
different
uh with different say types and number
and arguments but having the same name
um in the same class then what python
will do is it will only recognize
the the last defined method and
it will not recognize any of the earlier
methods with the same name
but we can simulate polymorphism through
method overloading by using default
arguments in a method
now for example what i'm going to show
you here is an example where i have
a method called sum now by default uh it
has
three attributes that you can pass
through this uh method
a does not have a default value b does
not have a default value but if you
notice c
has a default value 0. so this is a
simple example
where i'm going to show you that the sum
method is
going to be used in two different cases
in one case
we're going to simply add two digits i
mean two numbers
and in another case we're going to use
the sum method
to add three different numbers so we
have this class overload demo within it
a method sum
and i have three attributes a and b are
have uh are supposed to be given by the
user since they don't have a
since they do not have any default
values whereas c has a default value of
zero
so if you see here in my first case i
have uh i first of all created a
an instance called over uh an instance
called od
for the class overload demo and i have
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
store the value of the sum of 7 and 8
in the variable sum now if you see here
i have not passed a third argument
so what this method is going to do is
it's going to take the value of c as
zero by default so it's basically going
to do
uh seven plus eight and it's going to
give us the sum for seven plus eight
and in the next instance i'm going to
give three arguments
seven eight and nine so now c will be
replaced by nine instead of zero
and then i'm going to get the sum of 7 8
and 9. so in this this is
not a very use not a very commonly used
thing
but it's basically a method just to show
you that we can actually
simulate method overloading in python by
using default arguments
so i've basically shown you how the same
how the same method
sum has been used to do the addition of
two digits and then in another instance
is doing the addition of three digits
it might look very similar but you'll
basically notice that
by having this third attribute c
i have a default value of zero i have
induced
some form of polymorphism through method
overloading
now the next way that we can induce
polymorphism
is through inheritance which is called
method overriding as well
now method overriding gives us the
ability to change the way or the change
the implementation of a method
in a child class which is defined
already
in one of its super classes now if there
is a method in a super class the method
having the same name and same number of
arguments in a child class
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the
parent class object the method of the
parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
child class will be
executed executed and it will override
the method in the parent class
so the appropriate overhead method is
called
is called based on the object type which
is an example of polymorphism
so let's look at an example to
understand this so we have a class
called person
and we have defined what we're going to
define the initializer is two attributes
which we have to pass called name and
age and we're going to store them in
self.name and self.h now we have a
user defined method called displaydata
where we are going to print
if this display data has been called
through the parent
called person um if it's going to be
called through the parent class
object then we're going to print in
parent class display method and then
we're going to print the
name and age that we have entered now we
have another
class called employee which is going to
be a derived class 1 person
so it's going to um so it's also going
to have an
initializer and this constructor will
basically um what what this
initializer will have is it'll have an
uh constructor for the superclass
where we're going to do this uh the same
initialization that we do in the super
class
but we're also going to store another
attribute called id
in self.employeeid and if you see here
we also have another method called
displaydata which is the same
named method from person but now if you
see in display data
i have every i have all the same almost
the same information i'm going to print
the name i'm going to print the age
but if you see the first statement i'm
going to say if i'm going to call this
method from
the employee object then i'm going to
say in
child class display data method instead
of in parent class display data method
to say that basically i'm invoking this
method from the child class
object and i'm also going to print on
top of the whatever i'm printing before
i'm
also going to print the employee id so
if you see here i have created an object
called person
which is an object of the class person
with the information of name john and
age 40
and then i'm going to display this now
next i'm going to create an object
called
emp which is the child class employee
object which is going to
now have the same information of john
for the name and
age 40 but now it's going to have an
employee id and then i'm going to store
this
in amp and i'm going to display the data
for this child class object and we will
see the difference in
how the display data is uh differing
from the earlier
earlier case so when i execute this you
see the in the first case
it says in parent class display data
method so this
display data has been called through the
parent class object and i'm only going
to
show the information of name and age
whereas when i
invoke this method from the employee
class object it's going to say
it's going to specifically say that it's
a in child class display method and then
i'm going to say the name
is and also the employee id over here so
this is the difference between how
display data
has been used in its parent and its
child class and this is basically the
example of method overriding
now our next example of polymorphism
is going to be through operator
overloading an operator overloading is
the ability to overload the operator to
provide extra functionality
in additional to its real or core
operation and operator overloading is
also an example of polymorphism
as the same operator can perform
different actions the earlier example of
where we use the plus operator for
different operations is an example of
operator overloading polymorphism now
when um
when when is operator overloading
required well
anytime you want an operator to perform
a different function for you in your
custom objects
you would basically do operator
overloading now an example of this
would be what i'm going to show you
below so if you see this class called
point
it has an initializer where i'm going to
store two attributes x and y
in sub dot x and y and septa uh instep.x
and self.y
now i'm going to create one object
called p1 where i'm going to create
point
one and two so you can think of this
object as basically like a coordinate
x coordinate one y coordinate two this
is one point and another point called uh
x coordinate three x one four i'm gonna
call that p two now i want to print p
one plus p two all right
now if i try to execute this you will
notice an error it says
unsupported operand types for plus point
and point this basically means
that plus does not know what to do when
it's given an object
of this type it has no idea what to do
whereas what we wanted to do is
add the the the x coordinate from this
point and the x coordinate from this
point so we wanted to do one plus
three and we also wanted to do this y
coordinate plus this y coordinate or two
plus four
and then we want to print basically like
something like four
comma six or the addition of the two
points
or the the vector addition of these two
points so this is what we
want this plus operator to do but the
python does not have any inbuilt feature
for the plus operator
and we are going to have to basically do
some operator overloading to create a
polymorphism on this
so let's see how we can do that so to do
that first of all we have to understand
that all operators in python
have internally defined methods to
provide functionality for these
operators
the operator or the special method to
provide functionality for the plus
operator in python is the add method and
whenever the plus operator is used we
are basically internally
internally invoking the add method so
these these sort of internal methods
that provide functionality for the
operators
are part of a big a bigger class of
methods known as magic methods
and these magic methods are
automatically invoked whenever
its corresponding operators are used so
we want to change
the or the operation for um the plus
operator in this example we are going to
have to use the
the add method in this case and since
it's a magic method
uh magic methods are also are basically
what we
saw earlier in the in the form of dunder
methods so magic methods are going to be
invoked using a double underscore uh a
prefix and suffix to it so similarly to
how we
defined an init of an init method or an
hdr method
we are going to also invoke the add
method using the same double
underscore before and after its name so
now let's see how we're going to do this
so if you see this class i have now my
class point and i have the same
initializer when i'm going to store x
and y now i am going to
define on uh these this add magic method
i am going to override
the the normal functionality of plus and
i'm going to give it a very specific
function
where i'm going to say um for two two
different objects
you're going to add it's uh the first
part the first part or its
so called x coordinate with the other x
coordinate and it the y coordinate with
the other y coordinate and you need to
return
return this to me in the form of a
similar object so
now when i pass one and two and three
and four it should return me 4 and 6
as you can see here i have basically
done what i wanted to do
by operator overloading i have changed
or i have overloaded
this add this plus operator using this
add magic method
and i have created a new functionality
for this add function
for these two points one and two three
and four now i'm able to add
one comma two three comma four in the
way i want it to
so now that you saw how we did operator
overloading
i'm just going to show you a list of
similar magic methods for different
operators that we
are familiar with so the plus operator
already we've seen
has the add method then we have the
minus operator with
the sub method and similarly we have for
all of these operations such as
multiplication
division we have its respective magic
methods these magic methods are again
prefixed with
two underscores and suffix with two
underscores and they are basically
they're also called uh
dunder's in python so this is how we
would do operator overloading in python
for whatever operator we want
similarly we can do this for like
comparison operators and for unary
operators as well so look at this
example
now where i'm going to overload the
multiplication or the
asterisk operator so i've again defined
a point
i mean a class called point i'm going to
define an initializer but i'm going to
store
some attribute x and self.x now what i'm
going to do is i'm going to overload the
multiplication operator
where i'm going to basically allow the
uh
this asterix operator to multiply two
objects
uh from like for example 12 and five
usually i can just do a normal 12 times
five but in this case my object is
slightly different
my 12 is being passed through an object
of a class called point and five as well
in another uh
instance of the same class now when i
want to multiply these
class instances like the the
multiplication operator does not
perceive these class instances
to be integer so by default it would not
be able to multiply
what we want to multiply but when we
define
um or we overload the multiplication
operator within our class it's
now able to understand what to do um
using the attributes of these classes in
its respective
uh class instances so it's able to say
okay
so i want this attribute from this
particular instance p1
12 and i'm going to multiply it with the
attribute 5 from instance p2 whenever i
say
p1 times p2 or p1 astrix p2 so when i
execute it it will give me 12 times 5.
similarly i can also do this for the
greater than operator over here so i
have a class called person where i'm
going to define an initializer
where i'm going to pass name and salary
and store them in sub.name server.salary
the gt method is basically the greater
than method
uh magic method and it's going to uh
we're going to use this to overload
the greater than operator and now again
using this greater than operator
i'm able to basically say object one
greater than object two and
i'm basically able to check through this
and if object one is greater than object
two it will basically tell us
if it is true or false or uh basically
whatever like we want to know
so basically the print statement will
check for object one dot name
and it will say earns more than object
two dot name if
in case object one is indeed greater
than object two so when i
execute this you can see here my first
information says john has is earning
4500
some units natasha is earning 6 000 of
some units so it will say
uh john earns more than natasha well
it's false because object one is not
greater than object two
so uh since 4500 is not actually greater
than 6000
and this is the check that i'm doing by
overloading the gt operator over here
where i'm so where i'm returning the
boolean value of uh what is greater
self.salary or other dot salary self
being the first
object in any comparison so in the if
i'm basically any comparison if i'm
doing
say if i'm doing 5 greater than 5
greater than 6
so what the gt will do is this will be
the self object and this will be the
other object so this is what i'm doing
over here
i'm checking self.salary with other dot
salary
in in the form of these objects and it's
basically the same
same way that we we are able to do five
plus five
through these class instance objects
that you saw earlier or 12 times five
that you saw earlier so this is
all examples of operator overloading in
python well this was
it for polymorphism choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description
to know more in this video what we will
be covering
is certain um abstract data such as
structure concepts
and we're going to also use we're going
to implement these abstract data
structures
using basic python techniques and also
we're going to get site introduction
into object oriented
programming to perform these
or to create these abstract data
structures so even consider this as an
exercise or an activity in
op plus some basic python concepts so
let's talk about what stack is
stack being the abstract data structure
that we are talking about over here
so the name stack resembles a pile of
objects right
it can be a stack of papers eight hours
of blocks where adding and removing of
an item occurs only at the top of the
file
so a stack is an abstract linear data
type which is a collection of objects
that supports fast
lasting and first out semantics for
inserts and deletes
and like lists for arrays tags typically
don't allow for random access to the
objects they contain
so you can't just access something by an
index in a stack
you either go from the top or the bottom
of the stack so what we are going to
use is insert and delete operations
which are often called push and pop
respectively
stacks and queues are both linear
connections of collections of items
but however in a queue the least
recently added item is removed first
so it follows a first in first out
approach on the other hand in a stack
the most recently added item is removed
in the beginning so it's like
last in and first out approach so
real life example of a stack is a pile
of heavy and precious plates
all kept on top of each other so if you
wish to remove a plate
uh if you wish to add a plate or remove
one you can only do that from the top
and if you want to remove a plate from
the lower bottom of the stack of plates
you have to remove from the top one by
one in a practical example of course
a useful real world analogy for
a stack data structures of course stack
of plates it could be a pile of clothes
as well
but uh you typically want to remove or
put everything from on top of the pile
and not in the middle or the bottom of
the pile
so yeah so this is a visual
representation of a stack where
this this whole it's a linear collection
but whatever we do is
usually uh something to do with the
top the the top most item or the last
entered item of the stack now basic
operations that can be performed in a
stack are mentioned
as follows so there's a push operation
which basically adds an item to the
stack
if the stack is full it is called it is
said to be in an overflow condition
there's a pop operation which removes an
item from the stack
it follows a reversed order to pop items
similar to the way
when items are pushed so in that case we
call it an underflow condition
now this peak or top operation which
basically
returns the top element of a stack and
then there's the smd
is empty operation which returns true if
the stack is empty and false if it is
not
now the applications of stacks like
where do we use them
they can be used to reverse a string it
can be used in
expression evaluation expression
conversion
it is used for forward and backward
features in web browsers
it is used in recursive passing in nlpms
and so many other operations are there
and applications for
stacks now let's understand stack
operations so the two most basic
operations are of course
push and pop now when we want to push
what we're basically doing
um let's consider an example so let's
consider editing a python file using the
undo feature
in our editor so you we have a clear
understanding of the stack operations
so at first say a new function called
insert is added
the push operation adds the insert
function into the stack so this is a
visual representation
of what we're talking about so we have
this empty list
this empty stack initially and what
we're going to push on to this
is the insert some function sale it's
called
insert or some some object called insert
so once we've done this
this stack looks like this it has an
object called insert right
now a word delete is removed let's look
at the next thing now let's say i i push
something called delete now onto this
right so if i push delete
some object called delete onto this it
goes on top of the insert stack
right because this is a stack everything
occurs in a top like
the last thing that you have added is
the first thing that you will see
from the top so we see delete first in
terms of our example of our python
script
assume the script as the whole stack
where we initially had a function called
insert and then we added a function
called delete
and now in the same script we want some
comments
for each of these functions so think of
it as another object that we're going to
add on top of all of this thread
so now we have this python script where
we have the first function
called insert the second function called
delete and a bunch of comments
pertaining to these and that's the last
basically that's the last object that we
added to our
python script now let's perform some pop
operations
so the first like say we did undo now we
have a python script with all of these
things now let's say we pressed undo for
something like say we press undo
well what is the first thing that is
going to go of course it's the last
thing that we entered right and the last
thing we entered was a comment
so when we press undo what gets popped
is the topmost thing which is the
comment
and the comment is now gone and what we
have left in the script is
the other two things and if we hit undo
again
well the next thing that would be
removed is the next most recent thing
that was added which was the delete
function
and then if we hit undo again the insert
function will get really removed
so this is how the pop function and the
push function works
in terms of stack where i gave you the
example of the undo operation in a
python script
now let's implement a stack in python
there are some basic implementations
and they they are as follows we can use
list we can use collections.dq
i'll show you what that is and we can
use the custom method which is basically
the oop example that we were talking
about
um and there are numerous third-party
package packages which we may or may not
look into
but for the the sake of this uh
particular video
we're going to be looking at these first
three cases in particular
so um let's look at the first option
which is a list built in
now the list the python's list object
type already has
a decent stack data structure approach
as it supports push and pop operations
by default so let's create a a list
called s
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
append this list with a bunch of strings
so it's
first i'm going to append it with each
sleep and then code so if you see here
if i print my list that i'm going to
treat as a stack these are my objects
right
now if i had to pop from this list your
question would be well what is the first
object that comes out of this list well
um
since we're going to treat this as a
stack and since pop is a stack operation
will pop out or it will remove the the
last most added the
the recent the most recent added object
which was
the string code right so if i had to
execute these
you will see when i do the first pop the
object that gets
popped out is the last thing that was
added which is code now if i did pop
again
it would remove sleep because that was
again the next most recent one and
finally if i did pop again it will
remove eat
uh it's important to note uh oops one
second
so if i do this then if i did pop and
then
okay so the so what happened here was
basically the pop
um okay so i'll tell you what uh so
let's look at an example
where i'm going to be using this so
let's define my stack as some list
s and i'm going to append each sleep and
code to it
so the first object that gets appended
is obviously eat
then sleep and then code so if i were to
pop these objects
the first object that should come out is
code followed by sleep followed by each
so let's look at what happens when i
actually try doing it
so let's print out what's in s if you
see
this is basically my my list my list s
now my first pop should remove code as
you can see
my next pop should remove sleep as you
can see finally to remove eat
now the question is what if i did pop
again well an underflow error would
occur
so if i did pop again you see this error
and it says you cannot pop from an empty
list
because i have popped every item which
were three items and the fourth pop will
well there's nothing else to remove from
the list so it gives me an error
our next option for stack implementation
is using the list
using the collections.dq so this is a
base
it contains basically python has a
module called collections it can
comprises of the dq class which is a
double ended queue
that supports inserting and removing
elements from either ends of this
of an object so since dq support adding
and removing from either side
they can serve both as queues and stacks
as well so let's import this
dq class and i'm going to create an
object called q
of class dq and what i'm going to do is
i'm going to do the same thing i'm going
to append each sleep and code
as you can see here let's check what's
in queue well it's a dq object type of
uh
it's it's an object of class dq with the
objects each sleep and code
so again if i did the pop operations it
should remove code sleep and eat
in that order because that's the reverse
order in which i have added them in
right
so let's look at it code gets popped
first
then sleep and then eat and of course if
i try to pop even further it will it
should throw me an error because
um there's it's an empty dq now there's
no objects left in it
now the third object is using custom
it's using custom method uh using
classes and objects
so this is basically our example of how
we're going to create a class and
use concepts of basic concepts of
object-oriented programming to create
our stack
so let's uh let's start working on this
the
so the following stack implementation
assumes that the end of the list will
hold the top element of the stack
as the stack grows basically as the push
operations occur
new items will be added on top of the
list pop operations will manipulate that
same end
so let's create our stack we are going
to create a stack class called stack top
n um it will have an initializer which
will basically initialize some
a list called items now once we've done
that we're going to
so this is basically the str function
don't worry about this
let's look at these functions which we
are concerned about
in this particular example so we have
a um after we defined our str function
which is basically what is going to do
is it's going to print the
contents of the stack that we have when
we invoke the print function for a
particular class object
now the custom functions sorry the
custom methods that we have created are
is empty
push pop peak size and display all items
they are very similar to the predefined
push pop
peak functions etc so what these will do
is the first function is empties
as the name suggests it's going to check
whether the
list call items is it empty or not if it
is
it will return true otherwise it will
return false based on this check the
push function
it's going to append an item whatever we
pass to the list
items the pop function on the other hand
is going to do the pop operation as we
have
already seen the peak function what it's
going to do
is if you see here it's going to give us
the item in the
last most index so if if a length of a
list is 10
then its last index is 9 since python is
0 base indexing right
and if we want that last index we can
just do length of that particular list
minus one
and then we can use that as an index for
our list so this is basically what's
happening here
um we're going to check for the last
item in the
list called items so yeah penultimately
we have another method called
size this what this will do is basically
return the length of
our object of our list of items finally
we have the method called display all
items which is going to
return the list itself so let's
initialize the stack
we call it s as you can see here let's
execute this
first now we initialize we call it s
now we print s what it does is well it
doesn't see it doesn't do anything
because
what the printf function should do is it
should return
us the stack contents which is nothing
right now
because there is we haven't entered and
we haven't added anything to our list
so we check if it's empty and we see it
is true
it is actually empty so let's start
pushing items into this list
so the first one that we enter uh that
we push into it will be called
will be a string called first then we
push second and then we push
third so let's do this once we have done
this
now if we print the uh this object s
it should give us the stack objects or
the stack contents which is
if you see here what i've done is
actually i've actually pushed
uh first second and third twice by
mistake so it basically contains a list
of first second third followed by first
second third again
again this is not an issue we can we can
work with this as well
now let's look at the most recent item
inserted
so since i have entered first second
third followed by first second third
again
so this list contains is basically a
list containing these objects right
like first second third followed by
first second third and
if i were to peak now what was the peak
function the peak function looks into
the last most object
so the peak function should look at the
object that i added
most recently which was the string
called third so if i print this
it should give me third which it does
over here now if i wanted to view the
stack
it's a simple i can iterate through all
of this and print each item
as you can see since i have added it
twice by mistake
uh what i'm going to do or what it's
going to do is it's going to give me
everything
as you can see here so it it basically
what this means is
my stack contains the objects first
second third first second third
similarly i can also use the display all
items to to do the same thing to show
the same thing
as you can see here now i can add a
boolean
so what this what this push will do is
it will add a
boolean object called true so if i push
this to it
now this stack contains a boolean object
called true
as the last object so let's see um let's
let's
uh so if i wanted to see what s contains
now
what i can do is i can do display all
items
and check let's see what is there now so
if you see i have my objects here but
now
since i added a true object you can see
that over here as well a boolean object
called true now let's print size of
stack
so we use the size function it should be
7
as you can see here now let's let's push
another object so this object is a float
object called 8.4
and once i pushed it and if i want to
display everything
as you can see now i have finally
another object called 8.4 in this
so if i were to pop now what will it pop
it will pop the recent most added
which was the float called 8.4 and if i
did that
as you can see i should get 8.4 here
finally if i were to
display whatever is left here it should
display everything
except the 8.4 which which i have popped
earlier on
as you can see so in this in this other
implementation what i am going to treat
uh the top
as is the beginning of the list so the
zeroth element is going to be my new top
now for the stack
so let's look at uh how things change
because of this
so again i have initialized a list an
empty list
and i'm going to have something an is
empty function to check if the list is
empty
i have a push which will basically now
not insert objects
from the last it will not append objects
anymore but instead what i'm going to do
is i'm going to insert objects to the
zeroth index
of the list item and when i do pop
it won't remove the item in the last
index but it will remove the item at the
zero with index
similarly peak function will also do the
same thing it will look at the
list from the left hand side so look at
the most the zeroth index object
so that's the peak and then the size is
the same thing it's going to return the
length of the list and display all items
will do the same thing once again
so now i have once i've created this
let's create an implementation called
stop zero
now is top zero initially empty it
should be true um let's push first
second and third now
once i push these let's look at what was
the most recent item that was inserted
which should be third right
let's view this uh stack like how does
it look
so if you see here if i print them one
by one it prints third second and first
so even though i've added first second
and third in this order
the items in which i retrieve it is
third second and first and that is
because of how i define this stack where
the top
of the stack is actually the zeroth
index so if i just
did if i did display all items it should
give me a list with third second and
first in that order
so if i execute this you can see this
over here
so again if i did uh just to see again
my peak will basically give me third
now using these concepts that we have
learned let's perform an exercise
um this exercise is going to be where we
are going to write a function
where we're going to reverse the
characters in a string
so let's look at how we're going to
implement this so if you remember this
class
stack top n uh from this from this
earlier
earlier case over here we're going to
use this class to create a
an instance of that class so what we're
going to do is we're going to call it my
stack
and our input string that we're going to
use is called bangalore we're going to
reverse the
characters of bangalore so what we're
going to do is
first of all we're going to push each
string
each character of the string into the
stack object
using the push function and then let's
see uh what our
object looks like so as you can see we
have pushed
each character of bangalore into a list
and
we've stored it right now for now so
let's initialize a
uh an empty list and an empty string now
what we're going to do
out here is basically the reversing
operation so as long as
my initial list which is called my stack
this object
as long as this object is not empty what
we're going to do is the pop operation
and we're going to keep the adding we're
going to append each
item that we get from the power
population and add it
to our empty string so we're basically
going to create a new string
with letters that we pop from this
particular list which is basically what
is going to do is it's going to pop e
then r and then o and we're going to add
it one by one in that order
to and create a new list a new string
out of it so this is how we're going to
do
a reversing string operation so
once we execute this and we're going to
print what is the reverse string is
so if you see here uh the reverse string
in the form of a list
is like this and if the the string
the string form of the reverse string is
as you can see here which is basically
bangalore reversed
as always i thank you for watching this
video i hope you learned something
about the stack the abstract data
structure in python and how we
implemented it
using basic python lists dqs and an
object-oriented approach to the same as
always like subscribe and share this
video with your friends so we can reach
out to new learners
i hope to see you in the next video and
thank you for watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here